In order to get rid of the term negative 2 3rd x on the right side of the
equation, we need to, as always, do the opposite. Since 2 3rd x is being
subtracted right now, we need instead to add it. This is going to leave us on
the right side with just 4, since negative 2 3rd x plus positive 2 3rd x equals
0. So nothing is being added or subtracted from 4 anymore. Over on the left
side, we now have x plus 2 plus 2 3rd x. If you'd have decided to take this one
step further and combine these two like terms, the ones with the x to the 1st in
them, you'd end up with 5 3rd x plus 2 equals 4. Just for future reference, I
personally prefer to write fractions in their improper form instead of mixed
sometimes. Just because that makes more sense in my head. Instead of 5 3rds, you
also of course could have 1 and 2 3rds x. This is just my personal preference.